even the minor characters on 2023's
Night Court have long acting resumes
from Colombo to Star Trek 3 here's where
you may have seen these familiar faces
before
Melissa Roush plays judge Abby Stone on
the new Night Court she's the daughter
of Judge Harry Stone who previously
occupied the bench for the Manhattan
Criminal Court's night shift Abby brings
the same approach to jurisprudence as
her late father treating those who
appear before her as people first and
foremost also they gave me this fancy
wooden Hammer so kind of get to do what
I want Roush was a huge fan of the
original night court she shared during
an interview with glamor I have such a
distinct memory of watching those
opening credits with the iconic theme
song playing I vividly remember being
transfixed by it in my childhood bedroom
Roush got her start in the 2006 film
Delirious alongside Steve Buscemi she
followed up her big screen debut with
roles in the comedy shows 12 miles of
bad Road and the American remake of Kath
and Kim Roush got her big break when she
joins the cast of the CBS sitcom The Big
Bang Theory as recurring character
Bernadette during the show's third
season she was promoted to the main cast
The Following season and played
Bernadette until the show's conclusion
in 2019. while she has worked primarily
in television Roush has had several high
profile film projects as well in 2015
she starred as hope and Gregory in the
sports comedy the bronze and the
following year she provided the voice of
Francine in Ice Age Collision Course her
voice over resume also includes playing
Harley Quinn in the 2017 animated film
Batman and Harley Quinn Nightcore is her
first major project since the end of The
Big Bang Theory British actor and singer
India de Beaufort plays Olivia the
assistant district attorney assigned to
Abby's Court in an interview with the
Mary Sue de Beaufort discussed why she
was so excited to be cast in The Night
Court reboot and how it continues the
legacy of the original I think what
we've done with Night Court is we've
carried over a place to disappear The
Joy the fun the lighthearted Spirit but
we've also made sure that as much as
you're laughing you're also occasionally
crying and you're invested in these
characters while you're kind of being
taken out of the everyday life which for
the moment put a lot of us very serious
de Beaufort got her start on British
television in 2003 when she was cast as
India on the family comedy the basil
brush show after leaving the kids
Centric Series in 2005 she had a
starring role alongside Simon Pegg and
David schwimmer's 2007 comedy film Run
Fatboy Run before making her American
television debut playing sire records
employee Miranda stone in One Tree Hill
since then de Beaufort has appeared in
numerous television comedies including
Chuck How I Met Your Mother and Two
Broke Girls she also appeared in the HBO
Comedy Veep as Brie ramachandran New
Orleans native John Larroquette has been
acting in film and television since the
1970s in the Night Court reboot
laroquette reprises his role as Dan
Fielding from the original a performance
which netted him for prime time Emmy
Awards and the pilot episode of the
Revival Dan no longer a district
attorney is working as a process server
before being convinced to return to
court as a public defender by Abby Stone
laroquette was initially apprehensive
about reprising his role but was
ultimately intrigued by the idea of
exploring how his character had grown he
said during a TV line interview how
often does an actor get a chance to
revisit some character that he played
three and a half decades ago laroquette
got his start as the narrator of the
Texas Chainsaw Massacre in 1974. for
them an idyllic Summer Afternoon Drive
became a nightmare his first major film
role came in 1981 when he played Captain
Stillman in the Bill Murray War comedy
stripes in the 1980s in addition to his
role on Night Court he played the
Klingon officer malts in Star Trek 3 The
Search for Spock and he was also in
Twilight Zone The Movie appearing in the
segment time out after night court
laroquette got his own sitcom about a
night shift on NBC the John larroquet
show in which he played recovering
alcoholic John Hemingway following the
show's cancellation after four seasons
he continued to appear regularly on
television popping up in shows like The
West Wing the practice Arrested
Development and house
one named actor lacrita plays Donna
gergs gurganus the new bailiff and
Abby's courtroom when she read the
script for the new show She was drawn to
how uniquely weird gergs seemed to be
speaking to theater Mania about the
experience of plangers lacreda said
she's smart she's just different from
our typical big black woman and I really
want to embrace that I've worked and
gotten to the point in my skill and
talent where I'm able to be honest as
well and not just be weird for the sake
of being weird Welcome to Night Court
over the course of her relatively short
career lacrita has worked primarily in
theater she played Gary Coleman in the
puppet musical Avenue Q and was an
ensemble member for the first national
tour of the Trey Parker and Matt Stone
musical comedy The Book of Mormon she
also originated the role of levora in
the Jukebox musical disaster which
premiered on Broadway in 2016. Kapil
telwalker plays Abby's clerk Neil in the
new Night Court in an interview with
bleeding cool he said that being cast on
a multi-camera sitcom was something he
had always dreamed about as a kid before
going on to praise star and executive
producer Melissa
Melissa is a unicorn of a human being
she creates the most amazing work
environment ever she's so positive and
she's like her character in so many ways
that she plays talwalker's breakout role
came in 2020 when he was cast as Tobin
in the NBC musical comedy Zoe's
extraordinary playlist if you're a fan
of the CW then you'll probably recognize
Tel Walker from The Charmed reboot he
played Dev across six episodes in 2022
Los Angeles native kimya bapornia plays
Maggie in the Night Court reboot she has
been active in the industry since 2012
when she played Shelley in the short
film treasure since her acting debut she
has appeared regularly on television in
2017 she plied her trade in two episodes
of the Loosely scripted comedy series
driveshare she also appeared in her
first feature film that year acting
alongside Brie Larson Samuel L Jackson
and Joan Cusack in the Netflix original
movie unicorn store her career really
began to take off in 2019 when she
played Rosie in the short-lived NBC
sitcom Abby's appearing in all 10
episodes two years later she returned to
the big screen playing the part of Marie
in the adventure comedy hero mode and
Landing the lead role of Emmylou Ponch
in the mockumentary film Marathon she
had a major supporting role in the third
season of atypical popped up in the HBO
Comedy hacks and recurred on the Hulu
original comedy series reboot before
appearing in the first season of Night
Court in 2023. she is also currently
providing the voice of watt in the PBS
KIDS show City Island actor and musician
Demeter maranath appears in Night Court
as Nikolai the Court's mysterious
maintenance man for his website he was
originally a classical violinist in
Bulgaria maranov began acting in ad
campaigns when he moved to the United
States in 1990. his first major role
came in the 2012 War Thriller Act of
Valor where he shared the screen with
real-life Navy Seals he followed up this
role with small parts and numerous
television shows including NCIS Brooklyn
Nine-Nine and the Marvel series Agent
Carter maranov continued to work
steadily in television into the late
2010s Landing roles in the Zach
Galifianakis comedy series baskets and
HBO's dark comedy Barry his big break
would arrive in 2018 when he was cast as
Dr Shirley's cellist in the historical
drama film green book the film would go
on to win best picture at the Academy
Awards and marinov became the first
Bulgarian actor to walk the red carpet
at the Oscars more recently he played
the hotel manager in the 2021 crime
drama the little things sharing the
screen with Hollywood would heavyweight
Denzel Washington
Eris Barr appears in the retooled Night
Court as the supposed psychic Esmeralda
the Magnificent she's been active in
film and TV since the turn of the
Millennium first appearing as a
Starfleet Cadet in a 2001 episode of
Star Trek Voyager the New Yorkers spent
most of her early career appearing in
one-off episodes of TV shows including
the Kevin James sitcom the King of
Queens and the final season of the
classic detective show Colombo in 2003.
her film debut came in 2006 when she
landed the role of Amy butlin in Larry
the Cable Guy health inspector she
snagged her first major movie role four
years later when she played Iris ryzen
in the horror film The Last Exorcism the
same year she created and starred in the
comedy series Svetlana which ran for two
seasons before being canceled one of her
most recognizable characters is Rachel
from Larry David's Curb Your Enthusiasm
she played The Devout Jew in three
episodes of the long-running HBO Comedy
more recently Barr appeared in two
episodes of ABC's the Connors and played
Perla in the HBO comedy series hacks
Brendan Jennings plays Howie in the
second episode of the new Night Court a
product of the illustrious Second City
in Chicago Jennings improv background
has gotten him numerous roles in TV
comedies since 2013. when he appeared as
Walt Koi pond in a season 5 episode of
Parks and Recreation his other early TV
roles include small parts in Cougar Town
and new girl in 2018 he briefly appeared
in the Breaking Bad prequel series
Better Call Saul as an office worker
then two years later he was cast in an
episode of Curb Your Enthusiasm his most
recent roles prior to Night Court were
as Dale in AP Bio Dennis in Superstore
and as Massacre Mike in the Netflix
comedy series The Woman in the house
across the street from the girl in the
window will Hines plays a customer
that's served in multiple ways by Dan
Fielding at the beginning of the pilot
episode of Night Court like Brendan
Jennings Heinz got his start in the
world of improv comedy he's an alumnus
of the Upright Citizens Brigade in New
York City and has written two books on
improv according to his website after
starring in some comedic web series he
appeared with Donald Glover in the Derek
comedy feature film Mystery team playing
Mr Stevens alongside several other
established improv actors later in his
career Heinz landed roles in a number of
TV comedies including Broad City
community and crazy ex-girlfriend and he
was featured in sketches on Inside Amy
Schumer he is perhaps best known for
playing Carl kerm on Brooklyn Nine-Nine
and Professor Bennett on the sex lives
of college girls podcast fans may also
know him from a series of appearances on
Comedy Bang Bang in addition to acting
Heinz has released two albums as one
half of the band Wayne and Rodney which
he created with fellow improviser Joel
Spence he also runs the online improv
School the world's greatest improv
School
Albion hadn't been acting for very long
when he appeared in the second episode
of Nightcore in 2023 he got his start in
the industry in 2018 when he played a
coroner in an episode of 9-1-1 and since
then he has appeared regularly on the
small screen popping up in a number of
big shows he followed up his debut role
by appearing in 2019 episodes of Good
Girls why women kill and the Oprah
Winfrey Network legal drama all rise in
2020 Bayonne landed his biggest role to
date appearing in HBO's critically
acclaimed dystopian science fiction
series Westworld he played a behavior
Tech in the season 3 episode the winter
line
foreign